[Music]  Dance Moms star avenue miller breaks  down in tears as the judge says block  her off  remember before she was sentenced for  bankruptcy fraud in an exclusive et  interview abby lee cried she  contemplated being sent to prison today  her worst nightmare became a reality  you go glad that at least it's over I  think it's just the young Abby Lee  Miller was confronted by reporters  outside federal court in Pittsburgh just  moments after she was sentenced to one  year and one day in prison followed by  two years of probation I feel uh relief  I feel peaceful do you feel like the  right  I know that I didn't make the right  decisions all the time here are the  details from inside the courtroom  cameras were not allowed but our  producer watched an emotional Abby Lee  sobbing court as she asked the judge for  leniency just before she handed down her  punishment the judge told Abby quote  somehow you got caught up in the fame  and lost your moral compass  [Music]  you